Wall Street opens this morning after the
Dow suffered its second worst points
drop ever it closed more than a thousand
points lower yesterday the worst points
drop in history nearly 1,200 points
happened on Monday the index is now down
10% from its record high on January 26
that officially puts it in correction
territory CBS News business analyst Jill
Schlesinger is here at the table you're
at the evening table you're at the
morning table much to discuss so it's
been two years since the last correction
does that mean we're really overdue i I
think so we have seen five or six
Corrections depending on which index
you're looking at since 2009 since the
bull market started and you know we're
almost at the ninth anniversary we
usually see Corrections every year maybe
year and a half so two years since the
last one is an awfully long stretch I
should also point out that it's also
been a very tranquil period over the
last couple of years until this recent
selling began we've had very little
fluctuation very few big down days so I
know it's jarring to see these point
numbers up on the screen but we have
been overdue so what will it mean for
the market and investors well I mean for
the market it is a breather and for
investors it's a pretty rotten week that
said most people who are investing they
know we're in it for the long term it's
fascinating retail investors people like
us who invest for retirement seem to be
taking this in stride it's the
professional investors who are freaking
out right now right and why are they
freaking out
regular people we've all learned now to
behave and not freak out but there are
people who are freaking out who are who
are they and why are they doing it well
there many of them are hedge fund folks
who are relying on mathematical models
to try to create a lot of value for
their investors and so what they did was
they put a bet on the table which is
kind of fascinating they said we believe
it will remain tranquil going forward
we're gonna own stocks but we think
there's not going to be a lot of
volatility all of a sudden the
volatility explodes and they've got to
unwind those trades really quickly the
volatility index which actually hit a
record low back in November popped up
this past week of trading in a way that
took them all by surprise all right Joe
thank you so much